all four empowering women to do what you
want to do like if you if you want to go
start your only fans go ahead say i'm
not gonna stop you
go crazy like get that bat but but
what i do think we do is like lie to
younger women and tell them there's no
consequences for that stuff
and and so we'll say like oh do sleep
with whoever you want and men won't care
they shouldn't care but they do care but
it depends if you think it's a lie it
really it's really like it's not it's
not it's not if i think it's a lie it's
like i have these
99 male followers i listen to men talk
every day they do care and biologically
there's a reason they care yeah i mean i
do do they care less than they did 100
years ago sure sure yeah yeah i don't
think like most guys want to but
i think most guys don't want their [ __ ]
on only fans yeah but then we can talk
about okay like let's get real like
women couldn't vote women couldn't have
jobs right black people were seen as
literally inhumane right and so you know
if we took that
that mindset back to where we were then
black people weren't human mm-hmm and so
you would not be sat here with us
because you would not yeah you would not
yeah i'm just a little confused what is
that like i just what is it
i'm just confused what did that have to
do with what we were talking about so
it's information too saying like we're
lying okay so then essentially the
people who went black people are people
they were liars back then okay
but this is this is what i'm saying it's
lying to women when we're saying like
statistically they're like for example
when you when you sleep with more men
you lose your ability to pair bond
so you have a harder time bonding with
your husband later on like the person
that you marry and there there's
a million studies that'll back this up
yeah the people you sleep with the
less
like you you have a higher probability
of being divorced yeah yeah so so saying
to women empower yourself and sleep with
whoever you i'm not i'm not saying women
should be prudent not everyone wants to
get married and not everyone wants to be
parabonded not everyone and not everyone
is scared
no and that's that's fine and so but i
think we should give women all of the
information oh yeah so yeah so i'm
saying like if you don't want to be
married and you want to be like by
yourself if that's what you want to do
go go go do it i'm don't but like don't
i think a lot of times girls follow this
advice and they're not they're not
giving all the information but yeah
we're also just assuming that every man
is going to be like
you're worthless oh i'm not i'm not
assuming every man but i think the like
majority okay okay would you would you
prefer a girl that has slept with a
hundred people or slept with ten
especially for me ten yeah yeah and like
i think if you ask like yeah guys would
you prefer someone more pure or more
more of a hoe most guys are going to say
more pure yeah but then you see for a
relationship yeah but then you see who
and what people then you see who and
what people watch on social media or
porn or who they engage with and you're
like oh you're a hot celebrity or
something with a lot of followers or
someone who is very desirable or someone
who is and that's it nothing is black
and white the one thing i say about that
is i i understand about the whole
desirable thing but guys don't really
care
how much a girl is desired by other men
that seems to be more of a
woman thing that they'll use
pre-selected by other women does that
make sense so like you know
you said this example i'll be honest no
matter how many guys are looking and
thirsting over lizzo
i'm not going to be thirsting over her
you know i mean she's not what i would
look for whereas like you get someone
like jonah hill if he was just your
average guy no one would want him but
because of who he is and women fawn over
him a lot of them to see him attracted
because he's desirable to other women
does that make sense
yeah like 100 like i'm that's it i'm
unfortunately i i'm aware of the reality
i'm not like delusional um
but then i'm aware of the science but so
being that's it psychology has been my
life for the past like oh my god when i
started i started studying it
oh my god 12 years ago
um and so it's the understanding of why
its behavior has come become that way
and the anthropology and all of that
stuff um so i come from more of a
scientific fact but then i'm like i
obviously know my bias i obviously know
xyz but yeah like i'm not gonna i'm not
delusional in the lizzo being a big
woman is not
attractive but then you know like yeah
it's so so would you agree that we
should give like like the advice if for
a girl that wants to be married would be
to like sleep with as little men as
possible
if you want to get married to the
highest value guy you can
hmm no i'm not saying like be a prude
i'm not saying no no no no no yeah it's
like it's like you should want to marry
a man that wants you regardless but but
you don't think you don't think your
choices have consequences like no i
think there's a consequence right and so
you don't think we should be honest to
the next generation saying hey these are
the consequences for those actions if
you if you get on the internet and you
you post your naked body like a guy that
that's worth a date but one guy will
care and one guy
but but
do the guys you want care is the
question that's i think that's different
i think the the difference is the the
high quality guys that most other women
would want
he's more he's gonna care about these
things whereas there'll be some guys who
don't care but it's likely that those
guys that don't care are not the guys
you want but then quality again is
subjective like would you rather have
someone who just accepts you for who you
are and loves you for who you are and
your history because then porn stars get
married but the numbers porn stars okay
but here's the thing any other porn
stars though but here's statistically
actually not correct because i get
studied here's here's the thing the
numbers the numbers don't lie and
actions have consequences right and so
we could say oh it's subjective like
what is quality but like when you it's
supply and demand yeah like what what
kind of then why do we need to all fit
into the majority why do we like i'm
very happy being an anomaly i'm very
happy being oh oh like and i and i say
and i say go if you want to be an
anomaly go do it if that's what makes me
happy i'm never going to tell someone
how to live their life but what i'm
saying is like why do we lie to younger
women instead of giving them all the
information
like why don't we say the younger woman
if you if you want the highest the guy
with the most options okay if you want
the highest quality guy you can attain
putting your starting and only fans is
not the best way to get there but then
it's like i don't understand like to me
like this is common sense and i feel
like we should agree on this and it's
almost like you like are looking for
that exception because you don't want to
like you don't want to because what
we're doing then is putting what he
wants and he desires and he values above
ourselves well because it's not always
about you
and that's that's what i'm saying like
he gets to choose who he wants to marry
and if you want we get to choose who we
want to marry no women marry who they
can no i don't know that's that's true
like women
they have to propose so we don't choose
we don't have to no no at all
but do you not think do you not think
would you agree that women decide you
have sex
yeah yeah
so would you not think that it is men
who decide who gets married
no because a woman can say no
or a woman can ask and a woman has the
ability to be like look if you're not
going to commit to me i'm going to walk
away no i know but men can also say no
to sex right but we understand that
culturally when it comes to having sex
it is women who decide get access yeah
but you women usually don't say no to
marriage either
the majority of women who are proposed
to accept
i don't yeah i don't know statistically
that was it and again it's because what
i mean is like you know you know that
when you stay from the first day of a
guy you know that he would have sex with
you straight away
so
nine times out of ten a guy is raised to
have sex before the woman that's why she
has the power to who has sex right
but also nine times out of ten it is the
woman who was ready for the commitment
so he decides who he commits to and i
think that's what pearl's saying saying
that when it comes to marriage
i think here's the thing like
before any woman has sex with a guy
she has he has to qualify himself to her
before she accepts that intimacy right
so the same is true
that women have to qualify themselves to
men if they want relationship and
commitment
but then so this then falls back that's
the patriarchy why is it the women
are the ones who are like i have to look
good i have to be hairless well why do
the men have to say oh i have to have a
good job i have to like a girl could be
unemployed a dude will still date her
but like men have to qualify themselves
to women too it's like like you're
trying to like take away the things that
men care about yeah and the things that
like the things that women and men care
about just are yeah well that's that's
why i'm very i'm i'm so frustrating in
that i'm very gray area i'm very so
that's it i've had men that are broke
men that are
objective i'm gonna say objectively not
very good looking men that are short men
that actually bring little to the table
other than being nice right and um so
but would you would you prefer a man
that like i would
100
prefer
a man that brought me more offered me
more but it didn't stop me from dating
other men it didn't stop me right but
then i think
i think i'm the anomaly in that but i'm
saying like you would still prefer the
man that had more just like the man
would still prefer the woman that had
had less guys yeah and i think like like
it just is i'm not saying i mean i mean
it's not like you know
like double standards just are yeah
i was gonna say as well do you know um
i think the difference is
that and this goes back to like what you
were saying earlier what we've all said
earlier is i understand the notion of
you know you said oh but you should want
someone who loves you for you
but we all acknowledged earlier earlier
that love isn't conditioned is not
unconditional like love is very or if we
say love at least who we choose is
definitely conditional and some like you
could meet a guy who you think oh he
rocks my world intimacy wise but if you
want to start having a family and he's
really not doing anything with his life
it's like you may really care about him
but you may not choose him over the next
guy who can do that for you does that
make sense yeah and then i think it also
depends upon like i'm gonna be real it
really depends upon your mental health
your well-being you're like so i settled
for people who treat me like [ __ ]
and if if someone outside when amy this
is what this guy is doing to me i'd be
like are you confused like leave him
like what the [ __ ]
um
and yeah like i fully like agree with
that i fully agree that like that's it's
just not a simple yes or no but so would
you would you would you then go back
because love is conditional would you go
back on your statement that like the man
shouldn't love you for you like it's
it's conditional based on the choices
yeah like that's it so yeah that makes
sense so so you would agree then to
younger women we should tell you them
that actions have consequences and going
on only fans might not be the best
action if you want a husband i think
well that's the reality is that yeah it
will have
yeah because it will some men won't care
some men will care right you have to be
okay and you have to be responsible to
be like i know that if i'm one only fans
some men are going to be like you're
trash and as long as you're okay with
that then and especially the men you
want just like like women that are
models who do they tend to date
oh hot models yeah yeah no no like like
rich men yeah rich men
men with the option i mean look at i'm
not saying like all guys that's like the
halo effect as well like if you are good
looking you are deemed to be more worthy
well then like a bad looking person no
it's more for women like men it's more
their accomplishments like us we have a
lot more value in our looks yeah which
we all we enjoy the benefits but that's
well wow oh and this is such an
anti-like feminist thing but
i will sometimes i will i'm
i'm a feminist but
in this world i'm like if i can back my
eyelashes and do the whole little cute
little ah i'm like no i will fully milk
yeah
i will do it and people like but you're
a feminist and you shouldn't do that and
i'm like look if i need to get ahead in
any way i can if i need to
be better looking yeah to come across as
better i'm going to be real well if i
came here looking like trash i think
that i'd get a lot like more mean
like i'm gonna i'm gonna be real
um
and yeah like no i totally like well i
think i think it's like we so it's
almost like like feminism they want
equality when it
it they almost only want it wow gray no
no i'm saying like we don't actually
want equality it's just equality when it
benefits us yeah so so here's the thing
because i think you're right
if you're going to call a spade a spade
you you as a woman you're gonna use
the advantages you have of being a woman
to get yourself ahead
right that's what you just said
yeah yeah
so
yeah that's
so then
can we i'm just playing devil's advocate
here can we then get annoyed at men
who use the advantages that they have
to get ahead
yeah but oh that's it it's it's not all
like it depends on the situation the
circumstance i'm so frustrating that i'm
very much like every situation
you can't blacklight i think it's just
when you have to answer a question that
goes against your belief system that's
what that no but that's no so because i
did dbt i'm non-judgmental and i'm very
much non
you don't commit you sit on the fence
because nothing is black and white
nothing and it makes life a lot more
enjoyable to not be so
committed to a certain belief or a
certain way of thinking i'm very
open-minded i'm very yeah i'm very happy
to be told i'm very happy for someone to
have a different opinion and to argue it
and i'm very much like oh do you know
what i've changed so i used to be very
yeah anti-abortion this is what really
surprises people i was very
anti-abortion as a teenager right and
then i
switched and i was very i was actually i
was a massive prude i was a massive
prude i was very judgmental on girls who
were promiscuous or xyz
and now i'm like the opposite
and i'm very open to it it's not really
it's not really like judgmental i i
don't i don't care what people do like i
don't i don't think who you sleep with
says who you are as a person like i
don't know i don't give it like you you
want to do that but i just wouldn't what
i don't like is acting like there's no
consequences for it no there are and
there is i'm telling young girls there's
no consequences because there are and
that would literally be a
a blank face lie because we know they're
right we know they're all right and in
an ideal world yeah there wouldn't be
but you've got to be you've got to be a
realist you've got to be a realist and
be like there are consequences to
certain men and if those are the men
that you're after then you have to
actually cater to what they want right
and right so yeah yeah yeah so we agree
yeah yeah in a real way yeah yeah yeah
yeah no
yeah like next question yeah no no but
like nobody is in a realist way like and
it's not something that i i'm happy
about or i want to accept it because of
who i am as a person i'm like oh okay if
a guy is like that's it your body count
matters or xyz matters then i'd be like
okay compatibility wise you're not for
me and they always say you know if you
wanted to he would or to one person this
will matter but to another person this
won't matter but
being realistic being that's it being
the reality of how life is how the world
is how society is how
[ __ ] matters [ __ ] has
consequences and you just have to be
okay with
being comfortable with the controversy
yeah i agree with that yeah so as long
as women and i do think it's a lot more
on women i really do so long as a woman
is self-assured enough and her
self-worth is to be like so i've had men
say to me and being like
um
i've had men be like oh you're not
you're not like
thick enough you're not xyz or
um i get told that i'm dramatic or that
i'm too opinionated or that i get told
i'm too much quite a lot and it really
impacts who i am as a person but then
all of my boyfriends so i asked a bunch
of them recently i was like was it
difficult to love and they went no
you're very easy to love
and they were like maybe difficult to be
with the times but i get a lot of guys
be like you're difficult you're too much
you talk too much and i'm like what i'm
hearing is that i'm abundant and you
can't handle me and i'm like i don't
want it is it possible because i get
that too i'm a chit chatter i love to
talk but it's just like it is too much
sometimes who cares you're not too much
they're not enough no i think sometimes
it's too much but it's okay like i'm not
perfect
then that's like the whole we know
there's consequences but i don't think
it like like it's kind of a bad
mentality to say like oh like i'm i'm
enough like i'll never change like
sometimes you're not something yeah
for other people you've gotta have that
middle ground between being selfish and
confident and then being humble
and then ah that's it you you want to be
palatable and accepted but you also want
to be
confident and secure and i don't care if
other people accept me or not and it's
uh it's messy
it's messy yeah i'm gonna read some
super chat